Connecticut
why can't we get a full committee good
morning welcome to the house special
committee on housing it is 1004 so we're
going to get started let's get started
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
okay
so the primary purpose of today is to
um dot our eyes and cross our T's and
get some of the rest of this language
down so
um the first thing
I'm going I'm hoping it's it's very hot
in here already there's no AC so I'm
hoping this is kind of a quick day
um I'm probably gonna take my coat off
I'm the first thing I'm going to do is
call on representative Damon who
indicated she would like to
um
bring something up
thank you Mr chair
um and I will informally say I really
wish you guys would all take your coats
off
um so the reason I asked for a few
minutes is I want some feedback on
the idea of proposing legislation to
um make sprinklers optional in
residential existing residential
buildings that are being converted to
three units
from single-family homes
with no increase in the number of
bedrooms so there's not a greater
there doesn't appear to be a greater
liability a greater risk
there was some mention of the issue of
sprinklers
in I think two or three different
speakers this spring I have not frankly
done the work to look back and see who
said that
and more recently the director of
planning and economic development in
Claremont Nancy Merrill who's been in
that position a long time very
experienced knowledgeable person
brought that up as a recurring issue
I think claremont's not unique in having
many of these old homes in various
levels of good or or inadequate
condition and there's a fair amount of
interest in making them into Workforce
housing
and the cost of sprinklers is
prohibitive on top of the additional you
know costs of all the work that is
required
so I had not prioritized this until
Nancy brought it back up last week
um
and I'm just looking for feedback from
people on
um what you think how to proceed clearly
need to navigate through the fire
marshal and see if we can come to an
agreement where they don't oppose it
so that's my question thank you
representative Lorenzo they can switch
here
um Governor Damon
representative Damon are you are you do
you have any idea of how much a
sprinkler building would cost of those
sizes
so I think that there's a lot of
variation
um
the preliminary conversation I had with
one Builder it was very anecdotal
noted that the the lines the pipes would
most likely be exposed because otherwise
it would really be cost prohibitive
um and he said 60 to 100 000 but I think
that was like a pretty much off the top
of the head so I need more info
okay thank you representative Rudy thank
you Mr chairman I think it depends on
the size of the house number one
um how many floors you have I mean if
you have to go up another floor there
could even be more
um
the cost is really
putting a lot of people out of the
market exactly for sprinklers okay in a
case like myself I don't know how much
they're needed
I cook a lot
and I bet you four or five times a year
my alarm goes off
and I just wouldn't want a sprinkler
going off at the same time
I mean I'm not a big fan of sprinklers
so you cook but you don't cook well is
I overcooked sometimes got it and you
know I read someplace if you undercooked
that means you're not cooking with
passion if you overcook you're cooking
with love so I'm always burning stuff I
um so oh representative thank you Mr
chair my understanding is that sprinkles
are activated by heat and not smoke so
you would have to be really burning
something to have a splinter go off
thank you
representative Reed
um so not knowing anything really about
this and certainly 60 000 sounds
a like it just can't be that much but B
yeah that would be super prohibitive
right
um so I am uh I don't know if this makes
me a less passionate cook but I I
support sprinklers in general but I if
you're not as you said increasing the
number of bedrooms and the cost truly is
that's you know astronomical then that
would be something and again this is
first blush and I'd like more
information but I on my knee-jerk
reaction is to be supportive
so I'm gonna call on Ben Frost to come
in and give us a little bit of context
in this Ben could you talk to us about
um if this is an existing code and would
this require an RSA or would this uh
require just an update to code or some
more flexibility thank you Ben thank you
Mr chairman Ben Frost from New Hampshire
Housing and I want to thank
representative Damon for bringing this
up uh there
as as you probably know uh state law uh
relative to the the building and fire
codes does not allow
for the requirement for sprinklers in
one and two family structures
and I can tell you right now there there
are discussions ongoing with the
building officials and with the State
Fire Marshal's Office about extending
that to three and four family structures
so four units
um
provided certain
conditions are met such as you know
independent means of egress for each
unit so external egress which would
require in some cases the construction
of
um
those things when I'm drawing a blank on
a stairs exterior external staircases
that are fire rated
um so I that that is something that is
going on right now I I don't
I think it probably would require uh a
statutory change uh relative to the
building code and possibly also to the
fire code I'm not sure I'm less familiar
with how the fire code is amended than
than the building code
so through so what you're saying is
through the legislature or the code the
code
could update to that
um because we could have representative
Damon file an LSR as a placeholder and
continued discussions with um the Fire
Marshal's office and and boa I think
that makes a lot of sense Mr chairman
okay to extend it to four units up from
two okay yes both for the building code
and the fire code and I encourage
representative Damon to check with the
Fire Marshal's office and also with uh
Bill McKinney from the state New
Hampshire building officials Association
he was here at the last meeting and I
have Bill's contact information
um and the Fire Marshal's office has
sent me an email as well so I'll send
over that contact as well
yes of course representative Damon so I
just wanted to clarify
um and thank you for your input and help
um
so the building code part of it separate
from fire code
is in RSA it's a would-need a
legislative address
there
the the building code is
um a statute that is primarily by
reference by reference to the
international residential code the
international building code the IRC and
the IBC
and uh the there are amendments to that
that are expansions or exceptions from
the IRC and the IBC
um
and those do require legislative action
generally speaking that is done through
the State Building Code review board
which makes recommendations for
amendments to those codes and those are
often done in a kind of a package bill
that embodies all of the Amendments that
but
so is there currently a bill going
forward a package of amendments to the
building code
um I can't say because we don't have the
the LSR filing period hasn't begun yet
um and it often goes in as a Senate bill
because of the later filing period
and given given the task of this
committee there's there should be
nothing stopping us if we see something
that we would like to submit separately
I think we're completely within our
jurisdiction to do that so I recommend
that you reach out to those peop those
groups and let them know
at least let them know or have them
coordinate with you if possible
representative Ocala thank you
um
I'm looking at uh it looks like RSA
153 colon 5. it says it was amended in
2010 to prohibit the State Fire Marshal
from adopting rules that quote require
automatic suppressant or sprinkler
systems in detached one or two family
resonance so that
all right right and so this is one of
the things that you might want to you
know discuss
um one 153 colon 5. and so
theoretically without even addressing
that
um the actual code you could just amend
that RSA I said I assume to just extend
it and I and just FYI I would also be in
favor of four that was up to four that's
what I was thinking so I think we're all
on the same page if I made Mr chairman
uh the other statute is 155 a that's the
State Building Code and I believe
there's a a an analogous provision in
representative Reed
thank you thank you again Mr Frost as
always
um so the four unit thing that would be
fairly uniform with a number of other I
think federal regulations and guidelines
am I correct that there's there's like a
and state for that matter I think that's
where we do the um what's the word
excluded or restricted restricted thank
you and unrestricted so
um so that would put us that particular
segment of the building code in line
with all these other kind this this
delineating line between four units and
more is like your true multi-family
I
yes representative Reed I think that's
generally true although different
statutes have different standards but
for example for
um
for a site plan review the a planning
board's jurisdiction is three or more
for Workforce housing the requirement is
five or more infrastructure but for uh
lending purposes for federal backing FHA
in particular
you can get a conventional single-family
mortgage for an owner occupied
four unit structure
thank you that's actually really good
information for me personally as well
and if I may just add a comment for uh
representative Damon uh I've had success
in the past with putting in lsrs as a
and motivator for the administration
um and I'm thinking because there's two
different moving pieces to what you're
talking about there's the delineation
between two units to four units but also
if you are converting a single family
home so like on the conservative end you
could say if you're converting a single
pre-existing single-family home and it's
not going to be more than four units
then there's no requirement for
sprinklers the more aggressive approach
would be either converting a single
family home regardless of the number of
units and anything with less than with
four units or less so there's two like
there's a more conservative approach and
more aggressive approach
anyway just just thoughts
and go ahead represent Damon
I just have one more question for Mr
Frost
is there any procedure for a homeowner
who is trying to do this kind of project
currently
to get a waiver of the sprinkler
requirement
yes I believe there is I believe the
State Fire Marshal has the authority to
Grant such waivers uh waivers or
variances I'm not sure what the right
terminology is for the the fire code
for the the building code
um
I
I'm trying to think through this because
municipalities can't adopt something
that is
um
less restrictive than the State Building
Code in their local building code
amendments and I think that that would
be construed as being less restrictive
you could pursue
um
a a variance I suppose and again I'm a
lot less familiar with the building
codes than I am with say Planning and
Zoning but there I imagine there is a
variance process that involves the local
building code board of appeals which is
typically the zba but sometimes is a
separate board Appeals
of decisions of which would go to the
State Building Code review board appeals
would then go to the Superior Court then
to the Supreme Court so it's a long
potentially a long process to get relief
thank you
so let me ask you if um this was
extended to four units in the state
would not require more
sprinklers for up to four units is
there's no language stopping a
municipality from requiring for does
that happen often
where where the the municipalities
requirements are more stringent than the
states
well right now Mr chairman uh sprinklers
would be required for three and four
unit structures
right so if this bill goes through I
guess my question is would miss valleys
be like well we don't really like that
so we'll
we will require three and four for this
town or this city no I don't think so we
would typically follow the guidance the
way the statutes are written
municipalities and there may be a
separate statute that addresses this
I've it's been what 13 years now since
we dealt with this
uh there may be a different statute that
addresses Municipal capacity and that
may be in RSA 674 which is where I think
it's uh section 51 right thereabouts
where municipalities can adopt
amendments local amendments to the State
Building Code
but I would check with Mr McKinney and
the State Fire Marshal on these
questions okay and my other question
would be for buildings that have three
or four units If This Were to pass
they would not be required to upkeep
those systems moving forward or would
they be required to continue upkeep of
them because that might also be
something that should be added
um so that there's no rule making
against that it's probably beyond my
portfolio and I check with the building
officials and the fire marshal and
representative and that's probably a
good question to ask too good okay
all right anybody else for Mr Frost
thank you thank you Mr chairman
okay representative Damon do you have
anything else I think this is a good
discussion to have not at this time and
I really appreciate the opportunity to
process and I will do my homework and
more than likely file an LSR and then
we'll come back to discuss it awesome
even if it's just a placeholder and
until you get language we're happy to
you know entertain it at a later date
thank you all very much all right okay
um represent McConkey do you have an
update for us good morning
thank you Mr chairman I've had
conversations with uh Phil throwbridge
manager land resource management program
on where to fit my proposed change for
stone and pipe and we keep going back
and forth which RSA if we need to add
something new I'm hoping to wrap that up
today okay if not I'm gonna let Ls I'm
on asked to draft it and then come back
to them and say you know do they agree
or disagree but all conversations all
conversations since we left here have
been positive with them
well I'm happy to even look at the
language if you send it to the committee
happy to just look at it and not reply
all and we'd have a discussion okay as a
committee at some time sure I'll do that
thank you that sounds good
okay anybody else
so I have a um LSR or a draft LSR the
committee should have it there's copies
on the table this kind of go along goes
along with the uh what we were talking
about last week regarding conditional
permitting
um so
the language is within um RSA two
sixty three that governs dot driveway
permits so initially like representative
Reed alluded to I wanted to do
restricted versus unrestricted for
driveway permits but
um the idea
instead was to use the language that dot
already uses for different unit sizes so
um the primary change
is in section two
I'm going to read this
before any construction or alteration
work is commenced said permit
application shall have been reviewed in
a construction permit issued by said
Department within 30 days for budding
properties as defined in RSA 236 and
within 45 days for budding properties as
defined in RSA 236 and then on the
second page we're adding a new section
that would say that would basically be
the Crux of it that would say if the
department fails to act within 30 days
for budding properties
and within 45 days for budding
properties the applicant may ask
Department to issue permit by submitting
a written request and if the applicant
has previously agreed to accept
Communications but from the Department
by electronic means a request submitted
electronically by the Implement
applicant shall constitute a written
request
So within 14 days of the receipt the
written requests of the applicant the
department shall either approve the
application in whole or in part and
issue the permit or deny the application
and this is the important part issue
written findings in support of the
denial
and then if the department does not
issue a permit or written denial within
the 14-day period the applicant shall be
deemed to have a permit by default and
may proceed with the project as
presented of the application
the authorization provided by the sub
paragraph shall not relieve the
applicant of complying with all
requirements applicable to the project
including not limited to requirements
established in or under this chapter and
any chapter rating relating to
so upon receipt of a written request
from the applicant the department shall
issue written confirmation the applicant
has a permit by default pursuant to
subcarov B without which authorizes the
applicant to proceed with the project
has presented so this would basically
I I think this is a rough draft of the
language I'd like to see I think
um representative McConkey kind of
indicated that you know when this was
implemented in another department it
kind of sped the approval of these
permitting
um so I think that this is a completely
reasonable request
um so it'd be 30 days and then a written
request of 14 days so that would give
them 44 days
um to approve these permits so we've
seen them go longer but I think that
this at least gives
um
it keeps the state working the direction
it should improve these approve these
permits or deny it in issue findings a
fact in support of the denial
uh representative Ocala
thank you Mr chair
um so uh following your
um language here it seems like uh C is
incorrect
um it would not be upon receipt of the
written request because the written
request is what triggers the 14-day time
period so it should actually probably be
a sub paragraph under B and then it
um expiration of the 14 days or
something like that that time period
where the um because you're saying that
the department shall issue written
confirmation that the permit has by by
default pursuant to share sub paragraph
B so that only happens after the 14-day
period right so you would only want to
issue that
um that they have a permit by default
on that 15th day essentially
and so I'm I'm happy for edits to this
committee if you think it's stronger I'm
I don't mind that at all I think that
the like I said the 30 days and the
additional 14 days is completely enough
and
representative Reed we have some go
ahead
I was it doesn't say that it was
defaulted the written request is
referencing
I'm I either I am confused or
representative yokella but I thought his
um point was that c was incorrect
because there is no written
um permit or denial because that's what
you're talking about but that's not what
C is saying it's it's saying that if
nothing was issued in the 14 days the
applicant can then have a written put in
a written request that the permit was
that's that's not what it says it says
upon receipt of a written request from
the applicant the request is on in the
request is made in
uh uh Roman Phi uh Romans 6 where it
says
um a request submitted
electronically by the Apple event shall
constitute a written request oh okay so
I was uh so you're interpreting that to
be as the definition of paragraph six
and I was interpreting that to be
defined as the rest of that sentence
um that the written request
referred to requesting the in the second
line of C confirmation that the
applicant had a permit by default
so maybe there needs to be a slightly
clearer language because we're using
written requests in two different ways
in this uh section
I see where the confusion is now thank
under a
is out
sub paragraph a I
um so I think it's placement is fine it
just needs to be clearer that written
request here is not the written request
in
um Roman numeral six but is upon receipt
of
um a letter
asking the department to confirm you
know instead of using that exact term
that's in in paragraph uh Roman numeral
six that the department will issue the
written confirmation that the applicant
was given a permit by default
it's it's the problem of using the word
written request in two different ways
where the applicant is requesting two
different things in this chapter
by written means and so
I don't know if representative yokello
heard my aha that makes sense two
different written requests is one of
them I mean yeah
defining written requests constitute a
written request and then if if the
chairman is a is meaning that after the
14 days there's an additional written
request then yeah I think it should be
more clear that it's a separate request
um a request for
issuance of you know documentation that
they have defaulted that's a different
because it's just having vague vague
language of written requests all
throughout this from the original
written request of the application of
the permit exactly two different written
requests
okay so I'm I'm honestly okay with
and now that I'm reading this I don't
really like the
in that paragraph B it says which
authorizes applicant to proceed with the
project has presented in the application
they're already authorized right so you
would just scratch that wouldn't you I
mean go ahead and just turn your mic on
thank you I think it's just essentially
yeah that the applicant wants some
documentation that they're able to
proceed so that maybe a building
official might be like you know their
local building official might be able to
um
verify that in some way I don't I'm not
sure that
um
like how would the building official
know that the 14 days has expired et
cetera et cetera you know what I mean
and so the problem is I guess if they're
taking 14 days to review the application
and they expire that then we're
imagining a situation that the that
they're so behind on stuff that they are
not able to complete it within the 14
days but there's no requirement that
they issue this written this uh this uh
uh
confirm confirmation that the applicant
has a permit by default you don't have a
time frame for that so they could take
you know six months to do that and if
the building per the local building
permit or the local building official is
not allowing them proceed until they can
prove that they have the permit then I
think you we didn't actually solve
anything right so okay I'm going to call
on um Ben Frost give us some background
on this and then we'll continue
conversation
thank you Mr chairman I'm still Ben
Frost still from New Hampshire housing
if
and I perfectly understand the the
question
I'm thinking from a
customer service standpoint
um
would it not be better to require the
Departments upon essentially defaulting
to issue a written permit rather than
making the applicant pursue the
department I'm okay with that too I was
reading into this so
um we could simplify this language and
just say after 30 days
there's a permit by default
um
is there any reason that legally that
the person building the driveway would
need to let dot know they have a permit
no I think the obligation is of the
department to issue the permit so that
the property owner can
show that to the the build local
building official to their bank which
may require legal access as well and
anyone else who has an interest in the
in the proposal okay so one more
question
um if if they're issued a permit by
default
dot does not issue the permit
I'm saying they should that that should
be required of the department if they
are required within they shall so we
need to add language that say they shall
issue within five business days or
something like that okay
um I'm gonna go represent burudi and
then representative thank you Mr
chairman I think if the department does
issue it they might want a disclaimer on
there saying that they haven't fully
reviewed it uh and it was issued by
default
I think the Department's going to want
representative
um representative Rudy basically made my
point that they can issue a permit based
on their findings or issue a permit
based on this is default we were not
able in the 14 days to come up with the
reason why this shouldn't be given so we
have to give it it's by default but it's
still a permit
so that would protect the state as well
yeah
I'm sure they'll come up with the
language represent Damon
so in that paragraph see on the last
page would we take out the initial
phrase upon receipt of a written request
from an applicant that they wouldn't
have to make a request I would I would
scratch completely see I'll just scratch
the entire thing
oh yeah I mean I think you could just
change upon written request to within
five business days the department shall
issue written findings that the
applicant has a permit by default to sub
paragraph B right that's good that was
the second half to put of what I was
going to say to put a time frame in yeah
Within
within five business days of the
expiration
so how many legislators does it take to
build a driver don't representative
Lorenzo thank you
um my question is um
what the public official who's making
the decision would they be able to get
an extension beyond the 14 day
period
not not the way this is written right
they already had 30 days and 45 days so
30 days is for
um smaller
unit or divisions and then 45 days are
for larger ones so the larger ones they
get a little bit more time okay
representative yeah so I think that the
30 days and 45 days already gives them
plenty of time and then you're saying
okay you haven't done what you're
supposed to do within the 35-45 days now
I'm giving you 15 days to do what you
have to do otherwise I get the permit so
we're talking about 45 minimum
was that fit 60
um
60 days total before issuance of a
permit so representative and the
department can buy some more time if
they ask for some more information as
long as they act
well it'll be uh in process if they act
on something and they ask for more
information I think that'll buy them
some more time and they're in you don't
see that I see it as if if they deem
that the application is not complete
complete or they need additional
they can deny the application and then
the application is resubmitted and that
obviously if the submit the if they had
a reason for denial then just denying it
and making them resubmit would be
another
um way for them to start the clock over
but it says
um
that the the language that he's adding
these 30 30 days and 45 days to is is
that the um
said permit application shall be
reviewed
and construction permit issued by the
department within so it's not just the
review but actually issuing the permit
within 30 or 45 days
um
not just asking answering asking for
more questions they could just deny
instead of asking for more questions and
then say okay now you have to submit
again and then we start our 30 days over
again well I think the denial though
they have to provide reasons why which
would and then would it would which then
the applicant can meet and resubmit I
assume well and any other on the other
hand they could approve it subject to
the applicant coming up with something
different I think that would be better
they would approve it subject to
something yeah I don't I don't see any
reason why that wouldn't be Allowed by
this
yeah I think that
that can typically happen with these
um okay so what I would do is is scratch
on I'm looking page two
B
I thought you only have to change C
M I thought you only had to change the
first part because that that indicates
the 14-day period right I'm fine there's
no more 14-day period we've gotten rid
of that we've gone to within five days
they issued the permit so you change the
14 to 5. so there's no EXT so if they
because because
in my opinion you know 30 days and 45
days is enough so right
um if you want to give them 45 and 60
days then then the 14 day extension
makes sense but if you're not then if
they haven't issued it within the 30
days or 45 days that we put then yeah
issuing the five by default within five
days well conditional I don't know that
it should be
conditional what conditions would if
they don't if they haven't processed the
report what conditions would they put
place on it
so they'd challenge you the permit yeah
shall issue the permit
um by default within five days of
so you're changing a
um
so because within within 14 days so
instead you would say if by the end of
the 30 or the 45 days neither of the one
or two has happened then B strike 14
days within five business days after the
expiration of that application period
um they will issue that
default permit right right right
I like how's the committee feel about
that I'm I'm fine with not having the
additional 14 days
I'm sure the department will come in and
ask for something else in there but I'm
okay with right now language I mean
getting rid of I mean we have two
different written requests that the
application applicant seems a little
more this seems this is Kaden we want I
want to streamline it right exactly
there's like two extra forms or whatever
that an applicant would be filling out
in addition to the original application
in this language that we are now getting
rid of so now it's just the original
application you say yes or you say no
and if you don't say anything you
automatically give the yes
foreign
okay and you automatically get the yes
and get notified of that yes without
having to have written requests of it
okay
great so I don't I don't see a reason
for the committee have to meet about
this again I'll just draft that and
submit that as an LSR
if that works
so I know this has been quick but does
anyone else have have any updates for us
represent Wallace do you have anything
not at this point okay
all right
so oh representative oh please update us
um I was appointed to the
what is that called the speakers
appointed representative yeah to the
housing Champion Advisory Board which
would advise report help with
um rule making process for what would
designate a municipality as a housing
Champion so instead of submitting
legislation requiring these things right
um so I don't rely on representative
guide yeah I'm not so that that
amendment that I drafted before as far
as
um adding l into
statute the requirements that I thought
the legislature should add I'm just
going to produce those
um
suggestions to that board which then
frees up
um
representative Reed to put a bill that
says that they are not suggestions if
you're a housing Champion but actually
just requirements from the state that
so
I have a question of the committee how
a Statewide like 10 acre minimum bill or
as in a pro prohibition on anything
minimum over 10 acres but they can still
have lower obviously because yeah well
my feeling is that we should have
learned our lesson from the Adu law that
says
if you suggest to the municipality that
this is the maximum that they will they
can do then they have a frequency of
putting that maximum as they're like
shooting target
um that that's what they're going to try
and do
um and so
I'm a little bit I understand and I
sympathize and I
um
would support the bill but I think that
we are
um
possibly
incentivizing municipalities to move
more with that legislation
up from two acre to ten acre where I
think that what we should be doing is
incentivizing them to do something more
like the
um
the D
e f the um
like soil basil yeah the soil based
suggestions from Des I think we should
be moving them towards that and away
from these arbitrary just I pulled this
number out of my hat
um you know one through ten just pull it
out and that's ours our minimum maker
lot requirement like I don't think that
that's appropriate I think that it
should be based on actual science and
because you know going back to what
representative Reed always says that
it's about health and safety and if and
and and
pulling it out of a hat is not uh health
and safety
and so I think it should be based on
actual uh representative
thank you
I was that kid in school
I know the answer so representative
viocella has the benefit of me having uh
run these ideas by him
um and I wasn't quite ready to out my
plan but I guess I will
um I am considering and I'm happy for
the um committee to weigh in on this and
I would hope that if I did put it in it
would come to this committee
legislation that would explicitly tie
zoning ordinances to health and safety
as per the what's it Nadine like I don't
remember the case name the the Supreme
Court the New Hampshire Supreme Court
case that said that zoning ordinances
need to be like this but we don't have
it in legislation and I would like I got
language from mercatus on this because a
number of other states have attempted
something like this I think the language
they sent me was from North Carolina and
um basically it's just saying that
zoning ordinances have to to be in other
words a municipality cannot pass a
zoning ordinance that isn't directly
tied to the health and safety of the
people and there's some like specific
examples for example it can't be for
assessments or the increased valuation
or whatever
um my because I don't like just doing
something really mean
um I wanted to kind of offer something
to the municipalities in exchange for
this and bear with me
there are a couple of you I think
representative baruti and representative
De Lorenzo have been around I'm sorry
have been around long enough to remember
that I put in
um twice over a cacr called the
community rights amendment that would
have enabled towns to pass ordinances
for the health safety and Welfare of
their people and that was specifically
targeting a lot of these big corporate
projects like USA Springs that came out
and like bought all of the water out
from under was it Lee or I don't
remember what town
um and so my idea my thought would be on
the one hand to enable towns in
legislation to pass those types of
ordinances that are for the help safety
and Welfare of the people but then at
the same time in the same legislation
prohibit zoning ordinances that don't
have to do with health and safety of the
people so it's it's a bit of a give and
take and I I probably shouldn't have
tipped my cards this early and not
having it fully baked yet but that's
where I'm going and I've got some
language from a couple of people to to
okay
anything else
I guess representative
representative Reed
um I guess I have a couple more thoughts
about
um like kind of on that same line as far
as discriminating against
um
homes with small square footage
is this is this a good conversation for
you guys
and and there was also some some
thoughts about
um
um RVs and tiny homes being
discriminated against right are you
thinking about doing anything with those
so the broad language for mercatus I
wanted to put in more specifics around
type of structure and technology and
that would extend also to what we were
talking about with septic technology
that everything has to be they can't Pro
discriminate against any particular type
or any particular technology so long as
the performance of said thing lives up
to the state or federal requirements
whichever is more restrictive so again I
don't have the the language flushed out
but I am looking towards doing like
getting the right language to aim in
that direction so that there is no
discrimination around type of housing so
long as it's suitable
um per state and federal requirements
there's no discrimination against type
of technology so long as it does the job
correctly so if I would very much
welcome your assistance in helping
perfect
all right great well thank you everyone
I think that I don't see a reason for us
to meet for the next
for a while
um so I'll keep the committee posted on
when our next meeting is but as of right
now we don't have anything planned
um I'll plan on hopefully everybody will
submit an LSR and forward that to the
committee so we can read them and sign
off on them but I would hope that if you
submit an LSR for the housing committee
you just flag it for me so I can let the
speaker know that it's something that
we've discussed in the committee so he
can hopefully send it our way
representative Damon and representative
so can you just clarify process for me
as the Newbie LED chair
so submit the LSR make you aware of it
and you send it to the committee I just
want to make sure we're on board with
the 91a yep you can submit an LSR and
then allow co-sponsors to be open to
only members of the special committee on
housing for a while and then once that
sign off happens then you can submit it
you know for senators or or other
members of the legislature if they if
they choose to but I think
my my purse my lsrs will only be open to
member of this members of this committee
first and allow them the possibility to
sign off and then we'll continue to the
rest of the legislature so OLS will can
handle all that if you let them know
so the OLS would communicate to the
members of the housing committee as
opposed to the person sponsoring the ls
Army you can you can flag that you've
submitted an LSR for the committee and
opened it up for co-sponsors okay thank
yeah I had some kind of question along
that same line because I was thinking
that generally you don't
you're not notified by unless you're
added as a co-sponsor
um
and then you're just Cho your choices to
sign off or not on that
um legislation so it would be my
preference that if you're doing anything
for housing or that you just add me as a
co-sponsor
um and then I can tell tell
um OLS no I don't want to be a
co-sponsor or yes I will sign off and
then then you'll know so then I get the
notification and so from from OLS
representative thank you Mr chairman I
think whenever anybody's files analysts
are that they should notify you number
one in this person amongst the committee
so we know which ones we want to jump in
on yeah
representative Reed I I agree that it'd
be good for everybody to notify each
other on this committee I will point out
and I'm not sure if it extends to lsrs
yet but the Nifty new tool on the
website that the clerk's office and OLS
and Tech have all come together to to do
when it's been in the works for many
years unfortunately is that you can
follow a bill and hopefully that means
you can follow an LSR so you can sign up
and and follow the updates on it
I haven't given that a try but that
that's good to know I'm going to try
that for some of mine
you should also tell your constituents
and this is something I put talk about
motivating I put in four different times
a bill requiring because the powers that
be refused to allow regular citizens to
subscribe by email to our house calendar
email
for the longest time forever it was only
state reps that were doing it and now
because I put in that bill four
different times and it passed the house
the first time unanimously
um but finally the the pressure gained
enough to uh the last time I said I'm
putting in an LSR I put in the LSR and
immediately within 30 minutes it was up
and running so as always I appreciate
your passion on not only this issue but
other issues in the legislature so thank
you representative Reed all right we are
foreign